- Well, what's the most amazing golf shot
that you've ever made?
- Oh, recently actually
recently I was competing
in this college golf showcase,
not in college myself,
but I was asked to join this
group and compete for charity.
So, it was like Darius
Rucker and myself were
on a team and Jerome
Bettis and Brian Urlacher,
they were on another team
and we had two college kids.
So, it was four against four.
We were playing out in
Arizona and we were losing
and it came down to the
last hole, the 18th hole,
final hole, final putt, $100,000 putt.
- This is like a movie.
- Yeah. It really felt like it.
$100,000 putt for charity
all the way across the green.
I'm calling it 75 feet at least.
And I make it.
(audience clapping)
- I'm gonna be real with you.
I've seen this and I
thought it was incredible.
So, I'm gonna show the tape.
- Oh good!
- It's amazing.
- [Riggle] Yes!
- [Commentator] Riggle for $100,000.
I bet he likes the sounds of that.
- Yes!
(people cheering)
- Let's go.
The golfers out there know.
They know.
- They?
- They know, they know.
- I'm not a golfer
and you're a superhero to me right now.
I watched that 'cause I was
like, oh he's come back on.
They were like, yeah, he's
this incredible golf shot.
And I watched it last night
and I was like, screw this guy.
I was like, you made that putt?
I was like, I couldn't,
I can't even make it next to the hole.
Like I'm real, I'm like Happy Gilmore.
I can drive the ball, but
I can't putt for anything.
But that was incredible.
- I felt very blessed, very lucky.
- Did you feel like you were flying.
Did you feel like you were
- I did.
- the coolest person
in the world?
- Can I tell you?
I actually had, the honest reaction.
I turned into a soccer player.
All of a sudden I'd ran
away from my teammates
and I ran away and it was
like, "Look what I did."
And then I realized, oh, don't do that.
And I turned around and ran back to them.
So, you can actually see it.
- That's exciting.
- I got embarrassed
that I ran away 'cause
I'm not a soccer player,
I'm a team player.
- I know, but whatever,
it was a great goal
if you're a soccer player.
So, it's fine.
You're incredible at golf.
So, there's that.